girl it's happening how are you feeling
how have the rehearsals been the
rehearsals have been
painful and humbling
it's really funny because you think you
can dance when you go to a wedding
or a club got the beat on i'm into it
i'm in the middle of the dance floor
sometimes i shut down the dance floor
totally different story here i realize
i cannot even do a full twirl without
falling down because i
i need to learn how to spot and i
learned that i need to
um take something from my ankles i did
not know
that i need to supplement my ankles with
more nutrition because they're not being
strong for me
oh no or do we have an injury in our
future not an injury but they just feel
really wobbly now so all those years on
heels
i don't think they help me much for the
dance floor okay
uh is it one of those things i'm with
you know you're you're at the wedding
when you can dance on your own you're
like i have
rhythm that's me are you now
fundamentally questioning that
my entire being has always told me that
i'm one of the best dancers
there is and then i walk into this room
i was actually
in this room rehearsing yesterday and
no i was i was i was told very boldly
like god not improving the loudspeaker
like right down to my ear said
no girl keep working
well how are you feeling about your
chances to get that mirror ball what are
you gonna do to go the whole way
you know okay so at first when i started
i i started picturing the mirror ball i
started picturing where i could put in
my house i was really thinking about who
they would pair me up with that could
help me win that mirror ball
and then as i've started actually
shooting
dancing with the stars became so much
more
so much more of a different experience
for me especially because of the
pandemic especially because i've been
out of contact with so many people this
is the first time that i'm
touching somebody that i you know i'm
connecting with them i'm learning how to
you know actually exchange rhythm advise
and
i missed that i missed that type of
contact so to be really honest with you
winning would be amazing
but this experience already is something
i've never had in my entire life
wow how are you feeling about your uh
cast members slash
competitors are you getting close with
them are you nervous to be around any of
them
can we just talk about the fact that i
just pulled up in the parking lot next
to aj
like next to a backstreet boy like that
doesn't happen
at trader joe's i'm not i've i've lived
here for 15 years i've never
you know and i pulled up and he's like
hey girl what's up you look good and i'm
like
thank you aj you know he's he's so cool
everybody's really awesome i mean
the person i binged watched all
quarantined is here carol baskin
can we just yeah she was actually in a
room next to us
and i had my ear to the wall just dying
to know what her song was because i was
thinking is it i have a tiger is it roar
like what is it
so i'm i'm i'm just really enjoying how
cool everybody is
and yet how unique everybody is too
well i have to ask how you feel about
carol because i would say a
controversial casting um i think some
people
think she's innocent and some people
have questions
after tiger king how did you feel i
can't wait to pull up
next to her in the parking lot let's
just say that i can get some questions
and be like well
how did your uh you know some other
ladies who love to
to have a little conversation and talk
how did the real co-hosts feel about you
going on the show what did they say to
you
they're i think they're sick of me
dancing on the show so much
like the real is you know our talk show
is so fun and we start
the show off dancing that they're like
girl
finally take this energy somewhere else
like we're done we've seen too many of
these moves
what they don't understand though is
those moves that i do
on a talk show are not the type of moves
that are going to win me points here
so they're all wishing me luck and
they're so supportive
what can you tease about the first dance
okay
so the first dance is very symbolic to
me because
it actually echoes the first date that i
had with my now fiance
which is the salsa and again
even then when i went on that date with
him what i was doing
was not the salsa
i'm saying this really humbly because i
can't believe what i'm learning now
is nothing like the moves i was doing
that day i don't even know how
i made it through that night but clearly
he liked what he saw oh so you dance
you danced on your first date so this is
a redo yeah so this is
oh this is the girl this is not a redo
this is about to be the 2.0 this is
about what
i'm about to show him on our wedding
night what exactly it was supposed to
look like i'm getting amazing the deal
even more
amazing um so this the show is all about
not just the dancing but the journey
how much uh will we learn about you i
know you're an open book but how
emotional is this gonna get for you and
do you see yourself
breaking down during it all oh
i kind of already started to really feel
the effects of
how proud this made my family if i'm
really honest it's funny because
you know i've done a lot of cool things
in my career and i i
i never really get a lot of
like i don't get phone calls and things
like that from my family they're just
kind of like jeannie's working hard
she's out there
killing it you know they don't really
remember what shows i'm on and things
like that and that's
i kind of love it because my family just
loves me for who i am but when they
found out that i was on dancing with the
stars
i mean this is a global show this is a
show that has been translated for so
many different countries
across the world i got phone calls from
people like my cousins in vietnam
don't speak english they were freaking
out my little cousins who never thought
i was cool i begged them to do a tick
tock challenge with me
they're like we're good now they're like
you're gonna be on dance with the stars
i have to tell my friends so for me
doing a show that just translates the
one thing
that we all relate to which is music and
memories
makes me so proud and
already my playlist got me emotional
because in the beginning you have a very
extensive interview
and they ask you about every song your
first kiss your first heartbreak
song that got you through things and
just walking through that list was very
emotional for me because these songs
i have i'm actually dancing the first
song
is the song that i listen to on repeat
driving from san jose to la to build my
dream the six hours
i drove every week back and forth and
this song was on repeat so
it's already getting very emotional for
[Music]
me